so let's say you want to make a game you
want to create a huge world with dozens
of characters the player can interact
with and a story that adapts to their
choices along the way now if you want
this game to release in the next five
years you're going to need a team of
professionals to create assets record
dialogue implement mechanics and manage
your team in order to pull this off
you're going to need lots of money a
shared workspace and team members
willing to commit hundreds if not
thousands of hours to turning your
vision into a reality
now imagine trying to make this game
without money and without a shared
workspace for large-scale mod projects
this is the harsh reality over the last
few months I've had the opportunity to
sit down with some modders from fallout
Miami and Cascadia to discuss their
upcoming projects and the trials and
tribulations they've faced over the
years some of these issues are inherent
to game development while others are
unique to the modding scene this is what
it takes to make a large-scale fallout
mod
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
last year a small modding team released
a two minute long trailer for a fallout
mod it's an ambitious mod that aims to
recreate Miami with a fallout twist
there are feral ghouls roaming the
beautiful beaches palm trees scattered
around the city and Charteris lounging
in recliners all of this is set to a
familiar rendition of the fallout 4
title theme shortly after the team
released the trailer it went viral and
now sits at six point five million views
on YouTube and is one of the most
anticipated fallout mods ever fallout
Miami takes place within fallout 4 a
story your quest begins in the
Commonwealth and takes you to the
irradiated beaches of Miami Florida from
there you will meet different factions
as you explore the vacation wasteland
arguably one of the most interesting
things about Fallout is how it twists
American history to create unique
futuristic settings and the fallout
Miami team is dipping into Miami's
history in order to give it a believable
spin Miami itself wasn't hit by a nuke
but it sounds like the Cuban Missile
Crisis and Bay of Pigs could play an
important role in fallout Miami's
apocalyptic history however this being a
fallout game don't expect these events
to play out as they do in a textbook
wanna fall at Miami's project leaders
describes the Bay of Pigs as a
combined-arms operation complete with
laser weapons and power armor used to
push the Chinese out of Cuba well it
sounds like you won't be able to take
part in the battle you will hear a lot
about it as you explore if you've kept
an eye on the modding community over the
last decade or so you've probably seen
similar projects like this pop up
projects that garner a lot of attention
go quiet for years and either fizzle out
or if they're lucky release years later
a prime example of a large-scale mob
that crossed the finish line was project
Brasil also known as fallout new
California the project was
conceptualized in 2010 and released late
last year however mods like fallout new
California or Beyond Skyrim's Bruma are
the exception not the standard so let's
say despite the odds stacked against you
you decide to move forward with your
large-scale mod you design a map and
create a loose narrative next thing
you'll need is to recruit a team luckily
you've been entrenched in the modding
scene for quite some time now and you
know some killer 3d artists some crack
level designers and a couple of sharp
writers to join your project your team
is knocking out production tasks and
create
assets at a steady rate with that
creative burst of energy you decide to
expand you and your team put together a
trailer and upload it to YouTube
overnight it goes viral and when you
wake up you have hundreds of
applications in your inbox with a team
of this size you think you can knock out
your mod in no time k Constantine and
sir Balin to project leads of Fallout
Miami had a similar experience
after the team released a trailer for
their mod follow up Miami was first
conceptualized some time in 2016 by a
modder who goes by Myka 999 he began
working on a world space but never
really expected it to expand as much as
it did as the team was starting to ramp
up production they needed to expand
their team this is a common practice for
mod teams and it's usually why we see
trailers for mods so early when a studio
or publisher releases a trailer it's to
build hype when a large-scale mod team
releases a trailer it's usually because
they need to increase their headcount
that was actually one of the points of
the trailer and why we were pushing
ourselves to actually get it out we knew
that we have a really strong aesthetic
that people appreciate if they can see
it so we've needed people to see it then
but a lot of people's heart however more
people can lead to more problems it's
easy to keep track of a team of five
people keeping track of 25 to 50 people
is another story without a clear roadmap
a concise workflow and some management a
mod project can get derailed rather
quickly the last thing you want is for
your volunteers to be doubling up on
work or chipping away it's something
that got cut weeks ago in terms of a
project with something close to like 100
people that have contributed so far and
a pretty sizable active team you need a
sort of project management experience to
get things done and more goal oriented
and more corner oriented approach in an
office if you saw a team member working
on something that was cut you probably
tapped him on the shoulder and let them
know or maybe you'd hold an all-hands
meeting where you can share your updated
vision however with the team scattered
across different countries at different
time zones you can't really do that
another issue that can arise from a big
team is an ever-expanding scope being on
the outside it's easy to think oh they
have a much bigger team now that means
they can make the mod even bigger
according to Kay Constantine this is a
recipe for disaster and it's why fallout
Miami's size has largely
remain the same the scope didn't really
expand much at all because one thing
that is sort of a constant largemont
projects like this is that they don't
release things like new California are
very much the exception these things
just don't become a reality and one of
the problems with that is feature creep
in the cost of the expanding scope and
we wanted to keep things controlled you
want to kind of plan and stick to it but
that begs the question exactly how big
is fallout Miami supposed to be
according to Kay Constantine it should
be slightly bigger than fallout 4s
Bethesda developed DLC far Harbor the
world will be slightly bigger there will
be slightly more characters and this
story will be slightly longer the
restraint the team is showing might
disappoint some fans but like I said
before it's important to remember that
most of these large-scale mods never see
the light of day if anything that
restraint and focus is a promising sign
that fallout Miami will cross the finish
line the only thing that's happening is
the sort of the time horizon for how
long it might take to get this finished
has shrunk incredible so you've built up
your team you have a perfect roadmap and
an airtight workflow everyone knows
exactly what they should be doing and
when it should be done by but then your
lead level designer finds a job at a
triple-a studio your 3d artists are
buried in school work and your lead
writer is getting married and doesn't
have as much time to commit to the
project we've had people who show up
contribute on one assets were an art
asset and then had they have to leave if
we had people who joined the team and
actually don't even finish their first
project and have to leave we've had
people that join instead of state would
be team pretty much constantly since
they've joined after years of refining
and developing your vision with these
people they need to move on leaving many
of their projects half done the release
of your mod seemed far enough away as is
but now the goal posts have been moved
even further back not only do you have
to find replacements for all those open
positions but you have to catch everyone
up on years of work
while turnover can be a looming fear
when it comes to large-scale mods most
of the modders I spoke to didn't seem
all that worried a bigger challenge was
motivating and organizing volunteers who
have a fluctuating schedule and can only
commit a few hours a week to the project
however another fallout mod I took a
look at has an interesting history with
turnover
why the mod was first conceptualized
shortly after fallout 4 released by a
modern named Alex Cascadia takes place
in and around Seattle based on the
trailers and gameplay the team is shown
it's shaping up to be a vibrant and
imaginative take on the Fallout universe
that not only aims to expand on fallout
4 but take some of the Fallout series
best aspects and inject them into
Fallout 4s engine the team is
implementing a redone dialogue interface
that ditches the limiting dialogue wheel
and they are aiming to revive fallout
threes perk system a Mike Miami Cascadia
has almost nothing to do with fallout 4
settings story or plot the mod takes
place years after the events of four you
play as the drifter your backstory as
the drifter is more or less a clean
slate I sat down with the former Project
Lead Flynn Arne and the current Project
Lead Leon both gave me a similar
impression of the mod ambitious even
though leadership has changed hands a
few times it sounds like the team has a
clear vision of what fallout Cascadia
should and will look like however taking
on the role of Project Lead it wasn't an
easy transition the first day I became
Project Lead I woke up and I literally
had a hundred I had a hundred messages
waiting for me moment I woke up I'm just
like oh boy fortunately things are going
a lot smoother now however his sleep
schedule has been interesting part of
this is due to the fact that his team is
scattered across the world there isn't a
time that works for everyone and that
means early mornings and late nights so
he can coordinate with his team and for
a mod this big coordination is key
according to Leon the team plans to
deliver a map that is roughly twice the
size of Fallout fours in fact the shoe
size of Cascadia has caused a number of
issues on its own one in particular had
to do with version control which is away
modders and developers compile assets to
push out a build so we have this issue
where whatever we did we could add
nothing else to the file the creation
kit would not tell us anything it would
not air out it would just not let you
add anything and we actually had this
issue for about a month and a half if I
recall correctly where there were a
couple of us that were trying to work
behind the scenes trying to figure out
what was
going on and we just could not figure it
out at all and it's because our world
space is so high that we have a lot of a
lot more objects so I guess this isn't
really an issue that people would catch
but there's a bug with the creation kit
where once you hit a certain amount of
objects in the file it just will refuse
to let you add anymore
fortunately Leon in the Cascadia team
managed to get to the bottom of this
issue on the other hand Leon didn't seem
all that worried about turnover it
happens but it's not always as
detrimental as it could be even if
someone gets halfway through a project
before dropping off they can usually
find someone to pick up the slack
turnover with writers though can be a
bit more complicated when it comes to
writing that's really annoying because
then chances are it doesn't exactly fit
with whoever takes on that task next is
vision and then we they usually just
decide to redo it completely
[Music]
no matter how prepared you are there are
always going to be fires you will need
to put out and at the end of the day
investing hours and hours into a mod
usually won't pay the bills so why do
these modders dedicate their lives to
projects like these well for some it's
simply a hobby it's something creative
to do after work or class that builds
camaraderie others contribute to
projects like these to bolster their
portfolio and hopefully land a paid
position at a studio some do it because
they love fallout and want to put their
own unique spin on that world some do it
for all three when I asked Liana
Constantin why they spend day in and day
out working on their mods they gave me
similar answers they loved the Fallout
series and they wanted to make something
that fans would enjoy so when do these
mods come out you probably know what I'm
gonna say but I have no idea the teams
had rough estimates as to when the
public might get their hands on these
projects but anything can happen and
with all things considered I think the
very least we can do for these modders
is to be patient like you I am beyond
excited to get my hands on Miami in
Cascadia both mods are shaping up to be
an exciting take on the modern Fallout
series and both teams have something
interesting and unique they are bringing
to the table however I think it's
important to highlight the amount of
work dedication and sacrifice that comes
with projects like these even the mods
that fizzle out live on in some way or
another lessons learned from some of
these mods are taken and applied
elsewhere and sometimes assets levels
and characters are reworked for another
mod and in some cases someone with a
fresh perspective might pick up the
torch for a dormant large-scale mod and
push the project a little further thank
you all for watching this video there
are a couple of people I want to thank
for helping make this possible the
follow up Miami team the fall Cascadia
team K constant surveillance to project
leads behind Miami Leon and Flynn our
new Leon is the current lead of project
Cascadia and Flynn Arne was the previous
one who I interviewed at first and then
Cape Alto draws who made the thumbnail
for this video you should check out her
artwork if you get the chance and
finally all the music you heard in this
video are from fallout Miami and fallout
Cascadia so make sure to check out those
tracks on youtube if you did enjoy them
thank you
[Music]